couple of weekends ago me and the boys
at a game Jam called ladum dare or
ludume we had 72 hours to make a game
based on the theme every 10 seconds this
time around we made something that we
were actually really happy with a puzzle
game called dichotomy a word that none
of us had ever heard of before in every
dichotomy level your goal is to reach
the flag you have 10 seconds to execute
any kind of maneuver you want in the
sandbox before your moves are played out
in what we call the real world the
actual level being the real world though
it's full of danger with various deadly
tiles and traps that make completing a
level more and more difficult as you
progress through the game but we weren't
completely heartless we just had to give
you guys a Fighting Chance of completing
our game you have two abilities well
three I guess if you can count Movement
we brilliantly consider not adding move
into the game to make it a bit more
challenging but the undecided against it
anyway two abilities firstly tile reveal
space bar sandbox shows you the tiles
that would be immediately around you in
the real world now the best aspect of
this feature is the ultimate despair it
gives you when user's ability and
realize that actually you are already
already dead but you have to wait for
your time to finish in the sandbox
before you can dive for real inevitably
the player learns that the game is not
so much dichotomy as it is
dichotomy the second ability we've given
the player is the ability to slow down
time and that is really useful because
you can watch your shattered lifeless
player fall to bits in slow motion as
the field of view of the camera goes oh
I guess sometimes it will help you dodge
those swinging killing things when
playing dichotomy it's better not to
think of dichotomy as just a game or
some kind of puzzle to solve think of it
more as a simulation of your life in the
beginning the first 11 levels are so New
Jersey you go through the game facing a
series of mild challenges
some might seem difficult at the time
but you are able to overcome them think
of this as your childhood where your
parents cared and provided for you and
most of your difficulties were
self-inflicted only after completing the
first 11 levels will you begin to
experience the five stages of playing
dichotomy stage one denial you tell
yourself that you don't need to complete
this next level
stage two anger you break your monitor
keyboard and rage at the game and people
around you become seriously alarmed
stage three sadness you become all sad
and miserable because you can't beat a
level in a game made by Studio channel
for a game Jam stage 4 acceptance you
accept the fact that you won't be able
to beat this level and you delete it
Stage 5 reinvention you create your own
level and beat it oh what's this you
didn't know that we had a morning
support into this game out of the world
from the game every dichotomy map is an
11 by 11 pixel PNG image file stored in
this levels directory the game
automatically loads and plays levels in
alphabetical order from this directory
inside the image file every pixel
represents a tile there are three layers
in our levels which map to the red green
and blue values of each pixel with each
layer storing information about what is
contained within that tile by utilizing
different channels of the image we're
able to store more information about
exactly what should be at that tile in
the game let's take a look at this level
as an example if we look at the color of
this pixel we'll see that it has a red
value of 150 and a green value of 150
which means that the base tile is an
ocean deadly tile and there's a bridge
on top of it and that's how levels work
in dichotomy you can play our game for
free by going to the link below let us
know what you think and thanks for
watching